[музика]
Привіт друзі з вами пані Ліда і
ведмежатко бо Привіт
ми вивчаємо з вами абетку пам'ятаєте і
мабуть вже багато літер ми вже
запам'ятали з вами А що пригадати
давайте заспіваємо нашу пісеньку з
літерами абетки а б в г ґ д е е є ж з и
и йод і ще кал і ще раз давайте разом а
б в г ґ д е і є ж з і і йод і ще кал а
сьогодні у нас новенька літера і вона
дуже-дуже мила А чому вона мила тому що
вона називається літера м і звук м ось
Подивіться як він виглядає як виглядає
літера м Давайте порахуємо скільки
малючок Вона має ведмедику
чотири
вірно 4 палички і ми можемо сміливо з
вами взяти олівці або фломастери або
ручки Нам потрібно буде їх взяти 4
і скласти літеру м Ось таким чином ми
можемо їх викласти
так у мене тут різнокольорові зелений
фіолетовий коричневий і знову фіолетовий
і ось так ми можемо викласти
нашу літеру м і ще спробуємо написати її
пальчиком знизу догори не відриваючи
руки і знову зверху донизу
знизу догори і донизу і ще раз один два
три чотири вірно молодці у нас з вами
получилося
ви знаєте що ця буквочка м
мешкає у абеті і любить приймати гостей
і хто до неї приходить здогадайтесь ми
метелики м мурашки і навіть м мишки і
Мурчик котик а також вона любить
приймати діток
Марійку
маркіянчика і марчика а також дуже
любить їх пригощати знаєш чим ведмедику
молоко фруктами манго мандаринами
смачними млинцями і з медом А ще літера
м дуже любить малювати і малює вона
красиві квіти мальви
мімози і маки
така літера м дуже творча а також вона
любить
мріяти і знаєш про що вона мріє Вона
мріє про море
друзі А ви про що любите мріяти
подумайте
ведмедику Ти про що мрієш
я я мрію про подорожі Я люблю
подорожувати горами і любов не найвищій
горі в Україні яка називається
Говерла Ого який ти Розумник запам'ятав
гору на якій був так вірно найвища гора
України Говерла вірно А я знаєш про що
люблю мріяти є так само як і Літера м
дуже люблю мріяти про море
адже у слові море теж є звук м ось
гаразд гаразд ми з вами проговорили
багато про літеру м і звук м а ну
давайте його промовимо м м Ви відчуваєте
як ми його відправляємо це приголосний
звук і ще й губний ми губками його
вимовляємо м-м нам важко його проспівати
тому він і є приголосний ведмедику Ось у
нас є перша літера м і звук м ми читаємо
звуки пам'ятаєте і ми можемо тягнути їх
і утворювати склади так Дивися уважно і
починаємо читати перша літера м звук м і
тягнемо до голосної ма
Угу
молодці і знову йдемо в бік ми
молодці добре ведмедику твоя черга
гарно молодці а тепер ми можемо добавити
до наших складів і іншу буквочку Давайте
ви зараз його прочитаєте є слово яке ми
утворили
зайвими заберемо І що у нас вийшло друзі
це назва квітки слово
мак вірно молодці а зараз час на загадки
ось послухайте ведмедику Ти теж слухай і
спробуй від
у ворота він летить як зумієш гол забить
скаче весело по полю не замінний у
футболі що це може бути таке круглою
формою і ним можна бавитися у футбол у
волейбол Він навіть баскетбол що ж це
Так я чую друзі ви здогадалися вірно це
м'яч абсолютно вірно слово м'яч теж
починається звуком м м'яч гаразд і ще
одна загадка над глибокою рікою
вигнув спину він дугою всі по ньому
їдуть
йдуть а з собою не беруть Що це таке Що
єднає два береги і по ньому можна
проїхати або пройти ведмедику ти знаєш
що це так є ходив по ньому це
міст міст місток вірно м міст і звук м і
ще одна загадка хто крилатий гарний
гожий на красиву квітку схожий має
довгий хоботок п'єник тарний і з квіток
хто це такий Ти бачив колись таку
комашку
це друзі метелик
метелик вірно молодці скажіть а яких
кольорів ви зустрічали метеликів от я
колись бачила жовтого метелика
салатового коричневого у плямку і навіть
чорного метелика уявляєте А ви яких
метеликів бачили розкажіть тим хто поряд
з вами Ну раз ми заговорили за метеликів
у мене є гарний віршик про метелика
Давайте ми його з вами вивчимо напам'ять
А ви знаєте для чого ми вчимо віршики
напам'ять
для того щоб тренувати нашу пам'ять адже
м'язи ми можемо тренувати у спортзалах
різними спортивними секціями а пам'ять
ми можемо тренувати за допомогою
віршиків різних скоромовок тому Ну ми
починати ось послухайте
метелики просто чарівні природи казкової
діти такі кольорові і дивні літають
сідають на квіти вірно сідають на квіти
метеликів давайте по одній лінійці
спробуємо повторити разом
метелики просто чарівні ваша черга
природи казкової діти
[музика]
адже ми всі діти природи і метелики і
комашки і люди і тваринки
природи казкової діти повторила молодці
тепер два рядочки разом
метелики просто чарівні природи казкової
діти повториш ведмедику
діти вірно молодець і наступні дві
лінійки такі кольорові і дивні
ваша черга такі кольорові і дивні
літають сідають на квіти ведмедику такі
кольорові і дивні літають сідають на
квіти
[музика]
так і віршик Але він вам дуже гарно
вдасться вивчити його Гаразд Давайте
його повторимо весь разом
метелики просто чарівні природи казкової
діти такі кольорові і дивні літають
сідають на квіти тепер ваша черга
повторюйте Цей віршик і будете його
пам'ятати
Ну що ж а зараз час на гру я буду
називати вам слова А ваше завдання
знайти серед цих слів зайве слово А чому
вона зайве здогадайтесь
Отже готові малина
[музика]
намисто
відро
Яке тут зайве слово ведмедику
малина
намисто в відро може відро відро вірно
чому воно зайве тому що там не чути
звука м вірно і ще слова молоко
масло
лялька
яке з цих слів зайве
так зайве слово лялька тому що там теж
немає звука м і останні слова літера
лимон
мавпа
де ми чуємо звук м
лимон і мавпа А де його немає у слові
літера слово літера є Зая А нам друзі
час прощатись на все добре До нових
зустрічей па-па
Привіт друзі Усім привіт з вами пані
Настя і юстинка так ми дуже раді вас
бачити і зараз ми з вами
подихаємося Як вам зручно і випряміть
спинку Чудово не провалитись Ось так а
випрямляємо Чудово Ну і тепер ми будемо
дихати носиком Давайте зробимо вдих
і види
так само носком
[музика]
і видих
спокійний великий вдих
і спокійний виріб
чудово давайте з вами покладемо праву
ручку собі на животик а ліву собі на
грудну клітину чудово і тепер коли ми
будемо дихати ми будемо відчувати це
Повітря в нас всередині ми будемо
відчувати як наповняються на животик
коли ми вдихаємо і як він втягується
коли ми видихаємо Давайте спробуємо і
робимо вдих наповнюємо животик
і робимо видих
втягується животик ще вдих
і видих
втягуємо Чудово А тепер давайте відчуємо
як наповнюється наша грудна клітина коли
ми вдихаємо зараз ми не будемо відчувати
повітря в животику ми контролюємо ручкою
щоб туди повітря в нас не набиралось А
ми набираємо ось сюди в легені та наше
повітря одразу буде підніматися трошки
грудна клітина і трошечки подаватися
вперед давайте з вами спробуємо як це
відчувається робимо вдих наповнюємо
грудну клітину і видих
так ще вдих
і видих чудово можна покласти тут де
наші ребра можна покласти тут трошки
вище істинку треба покласти ось тут ось
тут Та ось тут до наші ребра ми зараз
будемо робити вдих
відчуваєте як вони розширюються правда і
видих як вони опускаються і наче
зменшуються так і ще раз вдих
і видих
Чудово Ну тепер знов покладемо Як в нас
були ручки права на животі а ліва на
грудній клітині і ми будемо робити вдих
спочатку в животик набирати повітря а
потім ще трошки в грудну клітину Давайте
спробуємо перше животик
набрали А тепер грудна клітина
і видихаємо
подихаємо ротиком і ще животик
і ще трошки грудна клітина І видихаємо
наче вдихаємо два рази і ще останній раз
Давайте спробуємо животик
і грудна клітина
і видихаємо
чудово тепер якщо ви маєте щось біля
себе таке легеньке Ну скажімо як
кір'ячко Чи як в нас це маленький
папірчики Візьміть собі Можливо у вас є
великий папір вам тоді будуть цікавіше
або якщо маєте навіть оце такий
малесенький то це вже буде
корисно щоб Ви подивилися як ми його
здуваємо так покладіть собі щось
легеньке можете придумати можете
покласти щось навіть трошки більше і
спробувати це здути можливо вас вийде
можливо це якась легенька іграшка або
якась кулька маленька буде або це може
бути кулька з пластиліну може бути
кулька з пластиліну спробуйте її здути
або наприклад якась маленька паличка Так
що ще може бути Можна спробувати якщо
дуже-дуже добре зробити вдих а тоді
сильні видих то можливо можна і картон
ступити Або можливо таку зубочистку
можна здути так
тканину якщо Маєте якусь хустинку
наприклад або паперову серветку дитина
її теж злити або вологий папір вологі
папір Мені здається буде складніше Але
можу у вас вийти
і потім розкажіть нам чи вас вийшло Окей
ми складемо собі на долоньку і для того
щоб це здути для того щоб воно гарно
летіло нам потрібно зробити щоб
так спершу вдих гарно для того щоб
зробити гарний вибір треба вперше
вдихнути правильно Та добре робимо вдих
і збиваємо ротиком
так і давайте ще раз
схопили покладіть собі на долоньку
робимо вдих глибокий і видихаємо
О В мене недалеко полетіло
дуже далеко тому що напевно істина
зробила дуже гарний вдих і дуже гарний
вид чудова друзі молодці Ну і останнє ми
з вами зробимо такі коротенькі вдихи
своїм носиком а видог майже не будемо
відчувати ми будемо насправді видихати
але не будемо це відчувати Давайте
зробимо в нас буде таких 5 коротких
вдихів Давайте так
але швидко треба Окей поїхали
Окей і види
х і ще 5
Окей добре Давайте зробимо ще один вдих
[музика]
і видих
ще один вдих і
він чудово Ось так ми гарно
налаштувалися на заняття на гарний день
та якщо гарно подихати то можна собі
покращити навіть настрій дуже раді вас
були бачити па-па друзі
[музика]